demant inadmissible que puissent
circuler sur des réseaux sociaux des
menaces contre la police ce soir comme
les ânes soir j'allais dire
malheureusement c'est une notion de
respect se perd petit à petit briefing
du préfet et du procureur devant les
policiers qui sont de service en cette
nuit du 9 novembre une nuit pas comme
les autres les forces de l'ordre ont été
menacés en effet sur les réseaux sociaux
des menaces à plat les attaques et
circulent tous les jours
la police agit pour la sécurité des
martiniquais des martiniquaises et donc
moi je voulais dire que quand il ya des
menaces qui sont proférées contre les
forces de l'ordre c'est tout simplement
inacceptable
cet acte est un individu totalement
irresponsable irresponsable parce qu'il
met ainsi en danger la vie des
fonctionnaires de police qui oeuvrent
dans les conditions extrêmement
difficiles que l'on connaît ici la thur
30 les équipes quittent le commissariat
elles ont été renforcées pour faire face
aux menaces
nous suivons la patrouille du
commissaire frédéric jean pierre on a
mis en place un dispositif ce soir parce
qu'on estime qu' on ne peut pas laisser
des jambes impunément comme ça va
vouloir venir s'attaquer aux forces de
l'ordre
la bac brigade anti-criminalité à
tergnier en tire sa ville un jeune homme
est contrôlé il sera placé en garde à
vue pour trafic de stupéfiants vernis
trois heures les policiers sont appelés
en urgence à rive droite levassor leurs
collègues se font caillasser des jeunes
que mes cheveux à la poubelle pour nous
attirer par ici qu'à l'école etc sont
arrivés et les ont caillassé et ils sont
partis en courant dans cette direction
alors autant dire que c'est leur secteur
c'est leur quartier là ça sert à rien
d'aller couvrir d'entre les fourgs et on
a quand même fait le tour là pourrait se
voir si on pouvait les prendre à revers
au fait un retour au poste mis à part
cet incident arrive doite levassor la
première partie de nuit a plutôt été
calme à 00h30 le dispositif spécial a
été levée
aucune attaque directe des policiers n'a
été recensé